what's going on Jane I'm doubting my
Christmas album I'm I have a big band
Christmas album called swingin a little
Christmas so they grabbed me and said
talk to the boys I remember the last
time I was here I don't think I talked
about whatever I was touting uh-huh and
we just had a great conversation I'm
open to any of it just download swing a
little Christmas on iTunes and then I'm
open I'm open for questions well I tell
you I'll take your calls I'm glad I'm
glad that you're making this album you
know why like because to me the want the
part of four year old virgin that
[ __ ] still makes me laugh every time
I see it is when you start singing in
Spanish yes I do I love that a little
inside information for you that is
actually taken from a dialogue or as we
said in Spanish class ideale go oh right
from the ALM Spanish a Spanish one level
one book is it a hard language to learn
believe me I have si I really want to
learn Spanish it would help with certain
online communications it's not French or
Russian or you know French is a Romance
language as well and they're both
Romance languages along with Latin and
Italian but maybe it's just because I
it's around it's more it's more
prevalent in ah me my mother made me
take French in high school cause she
thought maybe it would make me seem
smarter yeah it was like an educated
persons language which is [ __ ]
terrible I wish I had taken Spanish
because it's almost more practice no
practical use for it in the United
States that's you know there's no use
for Latin at all anymore unless you're
doing the the mass or being a Priya or
being a priest yeah I think well I'm
sure they still learn it but it's it's a
dead language let's face it a beautiful
language but it's kind of useful when I
was in Middle School they got all the
smart kids they offered them to take
Latin yeah like if you're smart just
haven't learn a language that you can
use you can master it yeah a master
Latin what are you gonna do yeah I know
nothing nothing with it except you know
maybe do an old-timey mass how many how
many years did you take it I took
Spanish for two years so I don't really
know what that well but I find a way to
butcher it and almost every character
that I've like created on my own I I do
bad Spanish well these these are weird
apps and stuff you can like you can look
things up immediately now and there's
that like when you're on base translate
yeah well you're in Facebook it's like
translate this so it's getting to a
point where I think eventually they'll
be able to map our voices so well
that you'll just talk and it'll
translate in what is almost your voice
yeah I guess I don't know I guess it
would take away the intimacy of actually
listening to somebody's inflection and
and it does do something about like
taking away culture yeah you don't have
to learn anyone else is called yeah what
stuff learn math anymore I mean it's
like all this stuff is like I'm grateful
for that
ya don't have any aptitude toward that
at all well you know I mean it's think
eventually it's just it's just gonna be
we're all just communicating easily it
won't matter maybe we won't even use
words anymore maybe it'll just be like
you know yes my points at genitals and
then money yeah that simple could make
interactions much much easier yeah it
certainly will so how are you doing are
you like a lot of a lot of folks are
coming apart and upset the whole
election are you like handling it are
you like yeah you know I and the
beginning was kind of tough it felt uh
it felt catastrophic boy stuff about
this one compared to like George Bush
he's like you're so many people in
Hollywood what is it that make people so
upset
well George Bush is a sane human being
you know and I'm just concerned about
Trump I did he was really ugly in the
election and he was you know it just you
couldn't predict what he's gonna do and
you know it makes I like Romney and
George Bush look like yeah that's okay
I'm even thinking might my prince is
fine right because at least you know
where he stands right you know Trump and
you just have to hope for his higher
angels and that they will you know and
there are a lot of people around him who
really think he's awesome so you gotta
hope that you know we'll learn what that
is at some point so far do you think
like the more I've only seen him talk a
little bit so far he's yeah it's been a
little bit of a difference yeah it is
it's a different guy and it's what was
it was very uh it was kind of a relief
to see him it was right yeah yeah kind
of nice
so do you people are hopefully the
reactions will kind of taper off I think
there's gonna be I think people are
gonna continue protesting is there's
gonna be there's gonna be vigilance in
terms of that really it could be could
be a tough time what is it people are
protesting what is it like what is the
basic theme what do they want I think
that people think that the race-baiting
and then yeah that he so doesn't
represent them you know what I mean and
because you got so I represent but
right yeah that's he said some things
that probably could be interpreted as
that definitely put you interpreted he'd
said them well I mean like yeah with the
Mexican thing got twisted a little bit
but he didn't say that well he didn't
say the immigration thing well wanting
well he said it well for some people who
are listening with a as with certain
ears yeah so yeah it's just gonna it's
it's um I think that we got to come
together though maybe this is our
opportunity yeah you know yeah but you
didn't do any youtubes of like crying
into the camera already part to me it's
a that people hating them but it's funny
to watch the this self-promotion people
are doing yeah weeping into camera just
to get it out there so people go look at
so-and-so's emotion yeah that's crazy
yeah if you didn't vote I don't want to
hear from I normally don't vote but I
did this time even though I don't say
hookahs votes are secret normally don't
know time and I guess I don't care if
somebody doesn't vote I really don't it
doesn't matter yeah well we probably
should we have to bring you let you go
to your next thing yeah yeah yeah I'm
glad you popped in so much you guys are
pin everybody go to iTunes and download
the Christmas album is that right little
Christmas okay that's very band big band
album and it's swings there's crazy
Christmas music is fun I love it it's
the best thank you very much